So we have already seen
that a multiprocessor
can easily win in performance nowadays,
assuming that you have a program
that can use multiple cores.
So there are some
disadvantages to going to
multiprocessors from
single core processors.
One is that the so-called sequential or
single-threaded code is easier
to develop for programmers, and
actually it's a lot easier to develop.
So there is significant
cost involved in making
an application multithreaded where
originally it was single-threaded.
Even when you do write a parallel
application you will have some bugs.
The debugging of parallel code is much
more difficult than sequential code,
and even if you have a program
that works correctly and
uses a lot of threads,
chances are that it will still be
very hard to get what is
called performance scaling.
And performance scaling is
a property of the program that,
as we increase the number of cores,
if its overall performance
keeps improving,
this will be ideal performance scaling.
You'll get more performance in
proportion to the number of
cores you are given.
Unfortunately, most programs, when you
write them, do something like this,
they scale for while and
then stop scaling and
eventually you stop getting more
performance from the number of cores.
You can spend a lot of time
improving this program and
get something like this, where it
scales up to some larger number of
cores reasonably well, but
each of these increments in scaling
is going to result in a lot of work for
you to achieve it.
And very, very few programs achieve
good scaling to a huge number of cores,
and those that do usually
took years to develop.